[Música]
bienvenidos a este nuevo espacio de
france 24 y es que para darle un
cubrimiento completo a la cumbre
climática de glasgow desde hoy y hasta
el 12 de noviembre tendremos un especial
de lunes a sábado a la una y cuarto de
la tarde en ahora bogotá quito lima en
directo con 26 hablaremos de los avances
que se logran en materia climática para
eso conectamos a esta hora con marina
colorado nuestra enviada especial a
glasgow marina bienvenida y hoy es el
primer día de esta cumbre cuéntenos qué
ha pasado hoy y por qué es tan
importante estar con 26
simari aclara por fin comenzó está con
26 desde glasgow escocia con un año de
retraso debido a como todos sabemos bien
a la pandemia de kobe 19 un retraso que
según recordó el presidente actual de la
cob 26 el británico alocs arma no ha
hecho que el cambio climã climático se
detenga ha sido un día más que nada
sobre todo de formalidades y de
planificación de la agenda más que de
decisiones porque las decisiones se
empezarán a tomar ojalá el lunes y el
martes 1º y 2 de noviembre
y los discursos inaugurales fueron
inaugurados por así decirlo por la
actual la presidenta de la cop 25 la
chilena carolina schmidt que le entregó
la batuta como decía a loc sharma el
británico presidente de la cob en ti 6
ella pidió que las acciones reflejarán
los compromisos de los países y nos
recordó que el cambio climático es una
prole una problemática que nos afecta a
todos por igual así que tenemos que
trabajar todos conjuntamente también la
directora de las naciones unidas contra
el cambio climático
patricia espinoza la mexicana mucho
latinoamericano presente dijo que
también tenemos que trabajar
conjuntamente para poder lograr
objetivos y que el tiempo empieza ahora
que las acciones y el trabajo tienen que
empezar ahora mismo porque es importante
esta cumbre porque llevamos dos años sin
hablar de cambio climático en altas
esferas y porque hay varios temas
pendientes que quedaron de la cob 25 en
fue el tema de la financiación para los
países menos industrializados
una promesa que desde el 2009 llevan
haciendo los países más ricos pero que
no se cumple de entregar 100 mil
millones de dólares al año para que
estos países se adapten o ayuden a
mitigar los efectos del cambio climático
también las promesas de reducir las
emisiones de los países a niveles para
por fin de conseguir la neutralidad de
carbono y otro tema más complicado del
que estaremos hablando estas semanas es
el de los mercados de carbono bueno y a
propósito de lo que usted nos estaba
hablando que el lunes y el martes serán
las decisiones claves y que las
emisiones y las finanzas verdes son los
temas importantes todo allí los
políticos llevan la mayor atención pero
también hay otros eventos donde los
protagonistas son miembros de la
sociedad civil cuéntenos más
claro que sí como bien dices el
protagonismo se lo suelen llevar los
políticos pero realmente es muy
importante y todos los actores de la
sociedad civil que están presentes en la
cob 26 y en todas las demás cop de hecho
me encuentro junto con uno de ellos él
es adrián martínez él es director de la
ruta del clima una ong que surgió en
costa rica y que nos acompaña para que
explicarnos un poco por qué es tan
importante que la sociedad civil esté
presente durante esas conferencias del
clima claro es muy importante que por
ejemplo la sociedad civil de él surgió
al y en especial de latinoamérica esté
presente en la cop 26 porque podemos
traer contexto podemos posicionar las
prioridades de nuestras comunidades
dentro de esa discusión y por ejemplo
traer a la mesa temas que están
olvidados como daños y pérdidas son los
impactos que estos tienen en las
personas que menos responsables son del
cambio climático al menos de los efectos
adversos del cambio climático de sus
causas y que se ven severamente
afectadas como pasa en muchas de las
comunidades en latinoamérica que sus
derechos humanos se ven violentados a
raíz del cambio climático nos afecta de
manera diferente
y precisamente hablando de los derechos
humanos ustedes van a tener algunos
eventos durante la duración de la cob
brevemente explíquenos de qué se va a
tratar claro mañana tendremos una una
exhibición dentro de lo que es la zona
verde donde estaremos presentando un
poco de nuestro trabajo y varias
investigaciones que hemos hecho sobre
los impactos de daños y pérdidas en
latinoamérica también en el 6 y el 8
estaremos teniendo este evento dentro de
la zona verde y la zona azul que pueden
ver en nuestra página web la ruta del
clima punto hereje donde estaremos
hablando sobre los impactos del cambio
climático y los derechos humanos desde
la perspectiva de diferentes
organizaciones latinoamericanas de
centroamérica y suramérica que hablarán
sobre cómo las comunidades y cómo la
población latinoamericana requiere la
compensación requiere que los daños y
pérdidas sean compensados y pagados por
quienes han generado históricamente las
emisiones como son los países
desarrollados del norte pues muchísimas
gracias a nuestro invitado adrián
martínez y a ustedes recordarles como
bien lo decía marx y aclarar que todos
los días de lunes a sábado estaremos
presentes desde la cob 26 aquí en
glasgow gracias marina y gracias también
a nuestro invitado adrián martínez y
como usted ya lo decía sigan con
nosotros en directo 26 para un
cubrimiento completo de esta cumbre
climática
[Música]